leafy and green and right in the heart
of the city the residents of the
apartment building vente Cinque Verde
have it all the facade is decked out
with 150 trees they're not just
attractive they also create a pleasant
environment and absorb noise 63
apartments are housed in this green
living project
hi I'm Anita and I'd like to show you
what it's like living here
Anita jure le has lived here for two
years now she moved in right after it
was completed
I lost a few knees on the left hand side
there's a small pool the whole building
consists of wood trees and steel as you
can see here these aren't real tree
trunks rusting steel it's the best part
of the house is the garden
well you're going down actually it's
more like a mini far enough for as that
50 trees are planted in the inner
courtyard alone in summer their leaves
provide shade for the apartments within
in winter when their branches are bare
they allow in more sunlight and warmth
reducing heating bills have different
plans and that sounds up there I'm going
to show you around now apart from steel
untreated larch wood was used
extensively in the complex both
materials change over time in keeping
with the natural world
if I come in let's look around our
apartment inside anita giarelli and her
family have 165 square meters of space
what you immediately notice about this
room of the huge windows which leads
straight onto the terrace the apartment
has an additional 72 square metres of
space outside we like eating outside in
the summer all of the terraces have
these huge planters it's wonderful
because you can see how the trees change
through the seasons and of course in
autumn it's particularly attractive the
special thing about the terraces is that
floors and ceilings are made from wood
and glass so the light can shine through
Aneta giarelli is a freelance translator
who works from home because of this room
I fell in love with the apartment while
my husband is working or on the phone or
I am we can watch the rest of the family
eating outside playing what is lazing
around in the rear of the apartment
there are two children's rooms and two
bathrooms from our bedroom you get to
the balcony that overlooks the inner
courtyards
watch this instruction step by step
because we used to live behind it we
were always very fascinated by what was
being created here Turki we always
wanted an apartment with big windows and
lots of greenery and in the end we found
it right outside our door life invented
Cinque verdi is not just aesthetically
attractive and environmentally friendly
it's also very sociable many of the
neighbors have already become friends
you